know this could be very challenging for
many of us it can be very very
uncomfortable
when you're putting up a situation where
you got to shake hands with the opposite
gender
and a culture that's very normal
but now i hope watching this brother
here
habib this is what men are made of
respect
for the woman respect for his wife
respect
for the sunnah of the prophet saw who
never did this nor his companions
and then respect for the creator of the
heavens and earth because
when we open that door of fitna
when we open that door it could be
something real small but then it leads
to the next thing next thing you know
the brother is going from
shaking to hugging and then who knows
zinna can be right
around the corner so hopefully this
inshallah can motivate us
because we're all weak human beings
we're all sinners we make mistakes but
when we see
a brother like this habib in the
spotlight media attention
you know and if he can do it inshallah
we could be strong enough to do it
and follow the sunnah of the prophet
saws